we got the Roe verse Wade you guys they
overturned Rovers wait is there more
news yeah I mean I I Louisiana is one of
the places where they just put it in
they had a they banned it yeah same with
Missouri where I live I'm shocked kind
of that this happened yeah
it's sad I for the first time ever
like I
hearing people say
you know don't tell a woman what to do
with her body like the people that
believe abortion is like literally
killing a baby
like I I kind of see their point if you
believe that it's a baby at a certain
like late term abortion I don't think
anything I wouldn't be for that and I'm
very approached and how late do they do
it I mean if it's real there should be a
line for sure like they can smile or
something I think you can't do it but I
don't know how they see that
you know what I'm saying though like if
it can like
yeah I mean there should be a line but
then it's like okay if you miss the day
before that line is that not like what
when is what's the [ __ ] line but
there needs to be one but I do see for
the first time when when you know people
people on the pro-choice side are saying
don't stop trying to control a woman's
body I mean I believe that that is what
they're trying to do but I think that
people that are pro-life a lot of times
they just think you're killing babies
and I kind of Sarah Silverman used to
have a I think a bit about like seeing
little girls with signs outside of an
abortion clinic you know picketing with
their parents and these little girls
literally think they're in their
stabbing babies which is like of course
you would be against that so I don't I
don't blame people that really think
it's a human life and and are against
that but I really think this is about
like wanting to punish women for being
[ __ ] like it's like you you chose to
you wanted to [ __ ] someone and and I I
don't know this is me kind of going a
step further I think
men want to punish women who don't [ __ ]
them so oh you want to [ __ ] someone
other than me you're gonna have to keep
the baby then you stupid [ __ ] I think
it's punishing women for being [ __ ] men
love [ __ ] when they're [ __ ] for them
but they [ __ ] hate [ __ ] when they're
[ __ ] for other men and I say [ __ ] says
like that's not what I'm calling them
that's what I think men I know you're
talking about yeah what men think women
just love Dixon so much when really we
have sex with men a lot of times not
because we love dicks and us but because
we want men to like us and to protect us
and we want to give you guys what you
want if this starts to happen though if
they shut down the uh oh yeah what's
gonna happen do you think like how do
you see that playing out just women
getting them illegally right it's just
going to be something for the elite
they're just or and they're just gonna
do it in unsafe methods and so there's
still going to be abortion but it's just
women around Streets back all right [ __ ]
that is so [ __ ]
it's gonna get an
risque out there
[Music]
honestly that makes me feel so happy
that out of all of that all of this that
makes me so sad you can make that joke
and like that wouldn't exist without
this happening and I'm grateful that
that joke can exist it doesn't make it
worth it but that that fact that I'm
always I'm gonna tell everyone about
this joke and that will bring a little
bit of joy to this very scary time to
just go back Streets back all right
damn yeah with the divorce and stuff man
what if they start going back to those
way like no it's so
yeah I've never had one
um and doesn't look like I'm ever gonna
be like I live in Missouri so I can't
get one anymore but I you know you just
I I'd be I'd find a way so people are
thinking to drive across state lines to
get them if I needed to yeah he's gonna
be like a little abortion wagons or
whatever like you'll see like a train of
just like
spent broads rolling through town you
know
you know just like legs hanging over
this out the side of the thing it's just
like we're taking them yeah we're taking
them all up north you know it's so
freaking I know
oh man
um yeah no the girl you can go to like
the underground snail Road oh my God oh
my [ __ ] god
okay
there's just gonna be Greyhound buses
full of freaking just just breast milk
leaking out the back of it just Charter
just like the [ __ ] uh gestation
Charters LLC just like all kinds of
crazy llc's opening up
there's a truck in these friends God
damn it Theo stop just Trucking these
[ __ ] serving Bros
you're contributing to the narrative
oh no look it's so sad it's ridiculous
man
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one